[Applause]
it's a vulnerable weird thing
like how how vulnerable do you get when
you go for it i always say it's so much
harder to do comedy than it is to do
drama because
if you aren't
fully committed with everything you got
and you got your whole heart out there
then people aren't gonna laugh it has to
be real or it's not funny and yet
do they laugh in the moment or have you
had to do comedy
where
it's you know
it's a set
and you know the
crew like is in a good way not bsing you
they laugh when they laugh and they
don't when they don't and you know you
kind of go like la da da
and there's no sound whatsoever
and you kind of walk home and you're
like okay
cool day just average day at work like
do what do you do in the silence when
you're going for it you know there have
been many a wednesday matinee where i
hit my punch line and there's a
you know it happens it happens on stage
too so you wait for it and when it
doesn't come you just keep going i have
never had the courage to do theater
i know i know what well tell me teach me
because you are an amazing theater
actress as well as a profoundly
successful sitcom comedian on a big
network but like what
happens in the theater when things don't
go according to plan or
what you know what happens magic that's
what happens yeah you know it's always a
happy happy accident happy mistake i'm
i've done many a thing on stage that
have uh you know been uncomfortable
awkward through the years i've fallen
i've tripped i've gone up on my lines
i've sang the wrong lyrics um i've gone
the wrong way i've you know fallen in a
hole all the things people's phones have
gone off and they've answered them and
walked out of the theater we've had to
stop a show it's never going to be as
worse as uh the time i peed my pants and
annie when i was 12. wait what tell me
everything
so
i was uh i was like 11 or 12 and it was
towards the end of the era of the age
where i could play annie and they were
doing it at this rec center and the last
couple
scenes of the show you cannot leave the
stage as annie and so i had a cold like
the last night of the run i was drinking
tons of water just so much water and i
got to the last song and i was doing
what i call the p dance you know when
you like have to pee really bad and you
doing that thing
so i sit down on my suitcase and i go
maybe far
away
[Laughter]
and i just
and i wasn't
i wasn't like you know seven or eight i
was like 12. you know solid 12 and uh
when it starts it it just it's it's not
going to stop so
i uh i jumped up and down for a pop quiz
the other day and i i might have piddled
a little bit i actually i was like well
that's two children for you um
okay
i um can i please quickly pick your
brain about impeachment
your portrayal of paula jones i'm all
caught up i've watched every episode is
extraordinary
it is incredible
you're giving this
performance that feels so relatable
when there's so much bubbling up inside
of you and you're trying to hold it all
in how do you do that
you know
at the core of this woman
i find her intention to have been so
heartbreaking
the reason that she came forward the
reason that she had to be in the public
eye
was because she was trying to please her
husband that was her main motivation i
think it's going to be kind of
surprising to people who tune in because
i think the women in this
narrative their story gets so lost
because of the way that we looked at
this story from a media perspective you
know these women didn't get to really
tell their story and so we're sort of
trying to do that now and so um
i think paula at her core was a woman
who was truly trying to please a man
well you have all the colors you check
all the boxes i'm just one of your
biggest fans and i love you and thank
you thank you anna lee ashburn be sure
to check out be positive thursday nights
on cbs and impeachment as well on fx and
fx hulu
[Music]
you